recep tayyip erdogan selbst preist in
diesem jubiläumsfilm den mut der kämpfer
von damals in der schlacht von balazs
kiss von über 900 jahren besiegten sie
die griechen auf dem blut dieser
soldaten wurde unsere türkische nation
gebaut schwärmt der präsident das
aufwendig inszenierte video schlägt dann
auch bildlich den bogen ins heute zum
kampf gegen die griechen um inseln und
rohstoffquellen im mittelmeer die
truppen von sultan alpaslan haben die
griechen damals geschlagen so die
botschaft und die truppen von sultan
erdogan werden es heute wieder tun
wir werden nicht vor dem kampf
davonlaufen und wir schrecken auch nicht
davor zurück
wenn wir märtyrer beklagen müssen aber
sind jene die sich uns im mittelmeer und
den umstrittenen zonen entgegenstellen
bereit die gleichen opfer zu bringen
kriegsdrohungen und glorifizierung des
osmanischen erbes für viele beobachter
zeigt sich darin die ideologie der
regierung erdogan
wir treffen den politikwissenschaftler
ilhan muskel der aktuelle konflikte
mittelmeer ist für ihn ausdruck einer
außenpolitischen strategie mit der
gründung der koalition von nationalisten
und islamisten begann eine neue
expansionistische phase in der
türkischen außen und sicherheitspolitik
ich würde sagen wir gehen im moment
durch eine phase des militarisierten
neos mannis muss diese ideologie steht
auf drei säulen eine davon ist eine
aggressive außenpolitik
die türkei sichert sich einflusszonen
außerhalb der türkischen grenzen längst
stehen ankaras truppen im nord irak oder
in syrien dort wurden große gebiete mit
der begründung terrorgruppen zu
bekämpfen schlicht militärisch besetzt
in libyen kämpfen söldnertruppen im
auftrag ankaras an der seite der
regierung in tripolis die türkei liefert
trotz embargos waffen setzt drohnen ein
dies alles folgt der strategie der
vorwärtsverteidigung
das ist eine strategie die in den
kreisen der türkischen sicherheitsleute
seit langem tief verankert ist sie
basiert auf der überzeugung dass sich
die türkische landesverteidigung nicht
auf die eigenen nationalen grenzen
beschränkt sondern dass sie auch
grenzüberschreitende region umfasst die
von der türkei kontrolliert werden im
mittelmeer gehen die strategen gar noch
einen schritt weiter dort träumen sie
von der blauen heimat wir treffen den
ehemaligen chef des marine
planungsstabes admiral john gordon ist
er hat die militärdoktrin navi bataan
blaue heimat vor 14 jahren entwickelt
sie sieht eine drastische ausweitung der
türkischen hoheitsgewässer auch im
mittelmeer vor einschließlich vieler
griechischer inseln nahe der türkischen
küste sei diese seegrenzen vor fast 100
jahren gezogen wurden sagt cordes habe
sich viel verändert im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert haben wir eine nation mit 85
millionen einwohnern ein g20 mitglied
ein land mit einer großen
rüstungsindustrie das unter die sieben
größten industrienationen aufsteigen
will
dieses land kann es nicht akzeptieren
aus dem mittelmeer ausgeschlossen zu
werden
griechenland und zypern beanspruchen
beide große wirtschaftszonen vor der
türkischen küste
diese lassen der türkei nur einen
schmalen küstenstreifen ankara
argumentiert mit seinem festlandsockel
und beansprucht seinerseits weite
gebiete die in die anderen zonen
hineinreichen
viele glauben es gehe der türkei vor
allem um energie nein um
energieversorgung geht es nur an zweiter
stelle
zuerst geht es um den ausschluss der
türkei vom mittelmeer
es geht um mediterrane geopolitik
jahrelang lag seine idee der blauen
heimat in der schublade erst erdogans
islamisch nationalistische koalition
holte sie wieder hervor
die aktuelle regierung nutzt die doktrin
der blauen heimat für ihre eigenen
außenpolitischen zwecke das ist
verständlich das würde jede partei tun
die an der macht ist aber ich bin ein
kerl ist ich halte nichts davon dass
diese strategie von religiösen kräften
wie den muslimbrüdern als
außenpolitisches mittel benutzt wird das
lehne ich ab
es geht um die ausweitung des einflusses
gebiets und dabei beruft sich erdogan
auf das osmanische erbe seine regierung
träumt vom aufstieg zu alter größe und
schleift das säkulare vermächtnis von
staatsgründer atatürk
jüngstes beispiel ist die rückumwandlung
der hagia sophia in eine moschee
nach der eroberung konstantinopels durch
die osmanen war sie 500 jahre lang ein
muslimisches gebetshaus wovor atatürk
sie 1934 zu einem museum machte für
viele ein historischer fehler
wir waren die ganze zeit schon sehr
aufgeregt gott segne unserer nation und
unseren präsidenten heute ist der tag an
dem wir muslime wieder stark sind wieder
in der hagia sophia beten zu können war
ein jugendraum des präsidenten
das türkische volk soll wieder stolz
sein auf die erfolge seiner osmanischen
ahnen die nutzung als moschee wird von
den streng religiösen und fielen in der
islamischen welt als sieg gewertet als
auferstehung des osmanischen geistes als
wiederbelebung islamische eroberung
dieser osmanische geist und die
islamischen eroberungen flimmern seit
jahren schon in aufwendig inszenierten
tv serien in die türkischen wohnzimmer
produktionen wie abdul hameed thron
erzählen von intrigen ausländischer
mächte und vom heldenhaften kampf gegen
den feind sie sind vehikel für die
propaganda der regierung erdogan und
bereiten das feld für die konflikte der
gegenwart
das verfolgt zwei ziele zum einen soll
erdogans regierung und ihre ideologie
gestärkt werden zum anderen soll die
türkische gesellschaft für die
grenzüberschreitenden militäroperationen
und das engagement außerhalb der eigenen
grenzen mobilisiert werden
für diese auslandseinsätze wurde massiv
in die aufrüstung des türkischen
militärs investiert besuch des
präsidenten beim rüstungsunternehmen
rocket sahen ende august eines der
erklärten hauptziele der türkischen
führung ist die entwicklung eigener
waffensysteme heute baut die türkei
eigene raketen kampfdrohnen panzer
kampfhubschrauber türkische
aufklärungssatelliten umkreisen die erde
am wochenende gab der präsident auch den
startschuss für ein eigenes
weltraumprogramm
meine brüder
wir haben in den letzten 18 jahren
versucht unser land im rüstungsbereich
wieder an die spitze zu bringen
unsere verteidigungsindustrie war fast
gelähmt inspiriert vom glorreichen erbe
unserer vorfahren konnten wir unsere
abhängigkeit von ausland im
rüstungsbereich von 70 auf 30 prozent
reduzieren
[Musik]
türkische aufklärungs und kampfdrohnen
kommen in syrien und libyen zum einsatz
türkische technologie für türkische
militär operationen im ausland sie sind
teil dieser villa es nennt neo
osmanischen strategie der
vorwärtsverteidigung
vermutlich wird die türkei bald
permanente militärbasen in libyen
einrichten
sie wird dauerhaft stützpunkte auch im
östlichen mittelmeer unterhalten
ebenso auf zypern sie hat bereits die
militärische kontrolle in nordsyrien und
im irak das heißt die türkei nutzt ihre
militärische macht um ihre politischen
ziele durchzusetzen
und genau diese botschaft will die
türkische führung senden wir sind wieder
wer
wir müssen uns von niemandem etwas
vorschreiben lassen auch nicht im
mittelmeer von griechen und europäern
wir werden unsere interessen durchsetzen
unsere blaue heimat verteidigen wenn
nötig mit gewalt